THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER HERE
LACKEY.
THERE MELINDA'S STONE.
WONDERFUL. MIGHT BE THE FIRST
TIME THIS YEAR WE'VE HAD
EVERYBODY AT THE BEGINNING.
WELL.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
ONE OF WELCOME YOU ALL HERE
TODAY.
WE HAVE A OF WHAT APPEARS TO BE
A FULL AGENDA BUT IF WE ARE.
DILIGENT ABOUT IT WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THE MAIN
PORTION OF IT AND THEN GET TO
THE HEARING AT THE END.
.
STAFFERS WORKED I THINK WITH OF
THE TWO STEPS TO WORK TOGETHER
TO TRY TO GROUP THE VOTING.
OTHER NUMBER VOTE ONLY ITEMS ON
THE ON THE AGENDA. AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GROUP THEM ALL
TOGETHER BUT NOT ALL OF THEM BUT
CERTAIN ONES WITH APPEARS TO BE
SOME CONSENSUS.
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE.
OF SIXTY NINE VOTE ONLY ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA. OF MOST OF THESE
ITEMS HAVE BEEN HEARD OR HAVE.
WE'VE HAD SOME CONTACT WITH AND
SO AS A RESULT SO WE WILL NOT BE
HAVING HEARINGS AND DISCUSSIONS
OF THE MATTER IS WE WILL BE
VOTING ONLY.
I IF THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT
MEET MY GROUPING CERTAIN WANTS
TO GET BUT JUST LET ME KNOW AND
AND IT'S NO BIG DEAL WITH JUST
BROKE APART.
OKAY WILL HAVE A FEW ITEMS THAT
THAT HAVE BEEN GROUPED TOGETHER
MY UNDERSTANDING WILL BEGIN WITH
ISSUE ONE WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTING
INCREASE. OF THIS IS AN APPROVAL
OF THE SPRING LETTER A ROLL
CALL.
WEBER HIT.
AYE JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT BRINGS US TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS.
ITEM TWO THROUGH FIVE THOSE
HAVE BEEN OF GROUP TOGETHER TO
TALK ABOUT POST PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING. RESTORATION ITEM THREE
IS A BORDER STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS POST RELEASE
COMMUNITY WHO PROVISIONS. ISSUE
FOR IS THE STANDARDS AND
TRAINING FOR LOCAL CORRECTIONS
IN ISSUE FIVE IS THE STATE
PENALTY FUND ADJUSTMENT.
THOSE FIVE HAVE BEEN GROUPED FOR
HAVE BEEN GROUPED TOGETHER FITS
NO CONCERNED WITH THEM BEING
GROUPED TOGETHER WILL HAVE ROLL
CALL.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY
I'VE MELENDEZ
STONE.
THOSE PRESS FIVE ZERO AND I
SHOULD INDICATE ISSUE NUMBER ONE
WAS ALSO FIVE ZERO.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX WHICH IS THE
PELICAN BAY. A PRISON FACILITY
D. YARD.
WE ARE PROVING THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER. OF ROLL CALL.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
BILL MELINDA. STONE.
THAT IS UP OUT ON IT THREE TO
VOTE.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS THE HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM. THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO REJECT THE PROPOSAL.
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY AYE MELINDA'S.
STONE.
THAT ITEM IS REJECTED WITH A
FIVE ZERO VOTE ISSUES.
AT.
THAT BRINGS US TO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT WHICH IS THE VISION OF
FISCAL AND BUSINESS SERVICES THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADPT THE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ROLL CALL WEBER AYE.
JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY NO.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
OKAY THAT BECOMES OUT ON A THREE
TWO VOTE TO ADOPT THE TRAITS
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE IS THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION EXPANSION
AND EQUIPMENT REFRESH.
APPROVED AS BUDGET IT
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY AYE AYE MELENDEZ
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE WHICH IS THE
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS IS APPROVED
AS BUDGET.
I'M SORRY TEN RADIO
COMMUNICATIONS APPROVED AS
BUDGET ISSUE NUMBER TEN BROKAW
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH IS HER
ROLE NINE RACIAL POSITIONS OF
APPROVED THE LA OLD
RECOMMENDATION ROLL CALL WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE WHICH IS A
REAL BILL TATUM ACHIEVEMENT
CREDIT STAFFING.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED
AS BUDGET IT ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER PIE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ NOW STONE.
THAT IS OF OUT ONLY THREE TO
VOTE.
A ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN THE
ACADEMY DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE APPROVE WAS BUDGET ROLL
CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
AYE LACKEY PART. MELINDA'S FIVE
STONE. THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
THE INMATE PAY APPROVED HIS
BUDGET ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER BY LACKEY. MELENDEZ AYE
STONE. THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN
WHICH IS THE OFFICE OF RESEARCH
RESOURCES APPROVED AS BUDGET
ROLL CALL WEBER I'VE JONES
SAWYER AYE. LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE
STONE. THAT IS OUT ON THE FIVE
ZERO VOTE ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN
THE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING
GRANTS APPROVED THIS BUDGET
TROCAR WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
HIGH LACKEY. MELENDEZ NOW.
STONE.
BUT WITH A GOOD FOR THAT IS NOT
ON IT READ TO VOTE. OKAY. I
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
REFORM AND MAY REVISION
ADJUSTMENT. APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION APPROVED THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
TRICK PLACEHOLDER TRUCK TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE.
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY. MELENDEZ NOW STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A THREE TWO VOTE.
THE VIDEO SO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
UNITS AT CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO. THIS IS THE APPROVAL
OF THE LA ALL RECOMMENDATION
WROCLAW WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY AYE AYE MELENDEZ AYE
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
BUT ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN THE
MENTAL HEALTH BID MANAGEMENT
APPROVAL OF THE LA ALL
RECOMMENDATION ROLE MODEL WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
IT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR MEN AND
RICHARD J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY FIFTY BIT MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS FACILITY AT EACH
LOCATION.
THIS IS A REJECTION OF THE
PROPOSAL. BROKE OFF WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ IN A PHILLIP SORRY I.
OKAY MELINDA I.
STONE. OKAY THAT PROPOSAL WAS
REJECTED ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE TWENTY ONE WHICH IS THE
MEDICATION DISTRIBUTION
IMPROVEMENT FACE TO APPROVE AS
BUDGET ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER HIGH LACKEY.
NO FOR SURE.
MELENDEZ.
MELINDA.
I.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FOR ONE VOTE.
OTHER HEALTH ACCESS VEHICLES
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TO IMPROVE
AS BUDGET IT ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
AYE JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
LIKE MELINDA'S STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
STATEWIDE MINOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROGRAM APPROVED THIS BUDGET
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE ROLL
CALL WEBER I'VE JONES SAWYER BY
LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE.
IF TAXES IN A FIVE ZERO VOTE
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR THE STATEWIDE
BUDGET PACKAGE AND ADVANCE
PLANNING APPROVED HIS BUDGET
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE AYE LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE
THE DUAL OF A VOCATIONAL
INSTITUTE BRIAN CONCENTRATION
SYSTEM REPLACEMENT.
RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED AS
BUDGET ROLL CALL WHETHER I'VE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO BOTH
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX WHICH IS
THE PELICAN BAY FIRE SUPPRESSION
UPGRADE APPROVALS BUDGET IS A
RECOMMENDATION ROLL CALL WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE. LACKEY
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
IT'S OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR MEN AIR
COOLING FACILITY IS A
RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED AS
BUDGET. BROKAW WEBER BY JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. MELENDEZ.
TWENTY SEVEN.
WHICH ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN.
JUDGE WHAT VOTE THAT DOUBLED
OVER TWENTY OKAY TWENTY SEVEN
SORRY HUN.
STONE BACK IF THAT IS OUT ONLY
FIVE ZERO VOTE. NOW ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS A PELICAN
BAY PRISON CLASSROOM SPACE.
APPROVED HIS BUDGET ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER BY
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
IF THAT IS OUT ONLY THREE TO
VOTE. ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON SACRAMENTO NEW CLASSROOMS
APPROVED AS BUDGET ROLL CALL
WEBER. HIGH JONES SAWYER BY
LACKEY. MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY THREE TO VOTE.
FOR ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR TREATMENT APPROVED AS
BUDGET ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER BY LACKEY. MELENDEZ
STONE.
THAT IS UP OUT ONLY THREE TO
VOTE. UP ISSUE THIRTY ONE
REAPPROPRIATION THE CALIFORNIA
MEN'S COLONY CENTRAL KITCHEN
REPLACEMENT WEST.
APPROVALS BUDGET.
VOCAL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER BY
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE
ISSUE THIRTY TWO WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL CENTER.
ARNAUD UNIT AN ANTELOPE CAMP.
KITCHEN AND DINING REPLACEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVALS BUDGET
ITEM THIRTY TWO. ROLL. WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE I.
OKAY THAT IS OUT ON A THREE TWO
VOTE.
ISSUE THIRTY THREE IS THE
VENTURA FIRED HIM APPROVE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION THE APPROVE
THE PROPOSAL WOULD WOULD PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THAT'D DOT ON A THREE TWO VOTE.
ISSUE THIRTY FOUR WHICH IS ROOF
REPLACEMENT AND MOLD
REMEDIATION.
AS APPROVED THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL.
I ISSUE THIRTY FOUR ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
MELINDA'S STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE.
MAY REVISION ADULT AND JUVENILE
POPULATION ADJUSTMENTS THIS IS
APPROVED THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE THIRTY SIX WHICH IS
PSYCHIATRY REGISTRY FUNDING THIS
IS APPROVED THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY. MELENDEZ
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS THE
CASE RECORDS TRAINING TEAM
APPROVED THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY. MELENDEZ
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
BUT ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT WHICH IS
A CORRECTIONAL COUNSELOR RATIO
ADJUSTMENT THIS IS A REJECTION
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO REJECT
THE PROPOSAL. ROLL CALL WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
THE OKAY THAT THAT ISSUE THIRTY
EIGHT IS REJECTED ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE. ISSUE THIRTY NINE WAS THAT
MEDICAL GUARDING AND
TRANSPORTATION THIS IS APPROVED
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL IS A
RECOMMENDATION. ROLL CALL WEBER
ACT JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT MONEY FIVE ZERO VOTE
ISSUE FORTY IS OVER TIME BASS
ADJUSTMENT. WE APPROVE THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL.
ROLL CALL WEBER ACT JONES SAWYER
BY LACKEY. MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE
ISSUE FORTY ONE WHICH IS THE
TRAINING INITIATIVES THIS IS THE
APPROVED THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL WOULD PLACE HOLDER.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BROKAW
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER BY
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ FORTY ONE.
STONE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE. ISSUE FORTY TWO WHICH IS
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR RE
ENTRY THIS IS APPROVED MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL ROLL CALL
WEBER BY JONES SAWYER. LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE IF THAT IS OUT
ONLY THREE TO VOTE.
ISSUE FORTY THREE WHICH IS
HEPATITIS C. TREATMENT FUNDING
THIS IS APPROVAL OF THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL BROKAW WEBER
I'VE JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
THIS IS OUT ONLY THREE TO VOTE.
ISSUE FORTY FOR WHICH IS A COURT
RE SENTENCING PETITIONS THIS
APPROVED THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL ROLL CALL.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE.
THIS IS OUT ON A THREE TWO VOTE.
ISSUE FORTY FIVE CONTRABAND
INTERDICTION PROGRAM THIS IS
APPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
WAS APPROVED THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL WITH A REQUIREMENT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO DESIGN THE
PILOT WITH EXTERNAL RESEARCHERS
TO PROVIDES SPECIFIED OUTCOMES.
ROLL CALL.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE.
THIS IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
ISSUE FORTY SIX WHICH IS THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE IDENTIFICATION
CARD PROGRAM THIS IS SO DOT
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. BROKAW.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
YEAH THIS IS OUT ONLY THREE TO
VOTE.
THE OF THE NEXT ITEM DEALS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ISSUE
FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS APPEAL OF
MET MEDICARE FRAUD AND ELDER
ABUSE TECHNICAL. REDIRECTION
THIS IS APPROVED THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL BROKAW WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE. LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
OF ISSUE FORTY EIGHT WHICH IS
CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM RESOURCES
THIS IS TO APPROVE THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL BROKE OFF
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE.
LACKEY AYE AYE.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THIS IT'S OUT OF A FIVE ZERO
VOTE APPROVED ISSUE FORTY NINE
WHICH IS A SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY.
THIS IS APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION APPROVING A
REVISION PROPOSAL AND TO ADOPT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A THREE TWO VOTE
ISSUE FIFTY WHICH IS A STATE
WIDE FORENSIC SERVICES THIS IS
TO APPROVE THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL.
WELL CALL WEBER BY JONES SAWYER
BY LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE.
THIS IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTES.
THIS IS THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES ISSUE FIFTY ONE
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT ADJUSTMENT.
APPROVED THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL ROLL CALL LEVER HIGH
JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
THIS IS A OUT ON A FOUR OH VOTER
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR. A.
FOR VOTING MEMBERS WHO MAY BE
OUT OF THE ROOM. ITEM FIFTY TWO
WHICH IS EMERGENCY RESPONSE
OPERATIONS THIS IS TO PROVE THE
LA ALL RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS
FUNDING POSITIONS FOR A TWO YEAR
LIMIT IT TERM. ROLL CALL WEBER
I'VE JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON THE FOUR OH VOTED
WE WILL HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEMS FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY
SEVEN.
.
OF THIS IS THE RECOMMENDATION
APPROVE THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS.
ITEM.
.
FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR DEALS WOULD HAVE THAT
MITIGATION PROGRAM WORKLOAD OF
FIFTY FIVE RECOVERY PROGRAM
WORKLOAD INCREASE. FIFTY SIX IS
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND
COLLABORATION TOOL AND FIFTY
SEVEN IS A DISASTER SERVICE
WORKER PROGRAM.
.
OKAY.
ANY QUESTIONS ON THOSE BEING.
.
PUT TOGETHER.
OKAY ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELINDA'S
STONE.
OKAY. THAT.
THOSE ARE OUT ONLY FOUR ZERO
VOTE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM FIFTY EIGHT
IS A CONSOLIDATION OF VICTIMS
PROGRAMS THIS IS THE APPROVAL OF
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE AND IT ADDS
A REQUIREMENT THAT THE REPORT.
WILL ALSO BE SUBMITTED TO
RELEVANT POLICY IN BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES A ROLL CALL.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
THAT'S OUT ON THE FLOOR ZERO
VOTE AND WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
A ITEM FIFTY NINE AND OF SIXTY
ITEM FIFTY NINE IS NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAMS ITEM SIX
IS A CALIFORNIA PUBLC SAFETY
MICROWAVE NETWORK. THERE'S NO OF
CONCERN ABOUT THAT WE WILL TAKE
THEM TOGETHER ROLL CALL. WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
OKAY OF THOSE ARE OUT ON A FIVE
ZERO AND WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM
SIXTY ONE IS A HOMELESS YOUTH
AND EXPLOITATION PROGRAM IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS AND
SERVICES THIS IS TO APPROVE THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL. ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER BY
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT ONLY FOUR ZERO
VOTE WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM SIXTY TWO
THROUGH SIXTY TWO TO SIXTY FOUR
AND THIS IS A PRO THIS SPRING
FINANCE LETTERS OF SIXTY TWO IS
THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
ALLOW JC TO ABUSE OF FUNDS
SOURCES FROM ITS OPERATING
BUDGET TO AY RENTAL OBLIGATIONS.
SIXTY THREE IS ALAMEDA COUNTY IS
HALL OF JUSTICE DATA CENTER AND
ITEM SIX
FOR IS A SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS ESERVICES WEB WEB
PORTAL WELCOME. WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY MELENDEZ
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT ON A FOUR OH
VOTE AND WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SIXTY FIVE TO SIXTY SIX
THIS IS APPROVED MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL SIXTY FIVE AS VARIOUS
MAYBE BUSINESS LOCAL ADJUSTMENTS
SIXTY SIX IS LANGUAGE ACCESS
PLAN AUGMENTATION.
BROKAW WEBER I'VE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FOUR OH VOTE
AND WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBER.
ISSUE A ITEM SIXTY SEVEN IS A
PILOT PROJECT FOR ONLINE
ADJUDICATION OF TRAFFIC
VIOLATIONS THIS IS A BOOK
APPROVE THE PROPOSED FUNDING
THROUGH TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND ADOPT. A PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE.
WROCLAW WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S OUT ON A FOUR OH AND WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND THE LAST TO VOTE
ONLY ITEMS ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH IS A SELF HELP CENTER THIS
IS APPROVED NINETEEN POINT ONE
MILLION ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS
THROUGH TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. TWENTY ONE AND ADOPT
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO DIRECT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO CONDUCT
A COMPREHENSIVE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OF SELF HELP SERVICES
AND REPORT FINDINGS BY NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY. ROCO WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
IF THAT IS OUT ON THE FLOOR ó
AND WE WILL ALSO HOLD THAT OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THAT
BRINGS US TO OUR.
.
SO.
ONE I CAN DO SPF SIXTY NINE AT
THE I DID THIS IN A NUMBER OF MY
PAID SIXTY NINE WHICH IS
COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE. LE THIS IS TO
REDUCE THE COMMISSION ON
JUDICIAL PERFORMANCE BUT ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINE BROKAW WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE. LACKEY
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY THREE.
.
THREE VOTES WITH THE.
LINDA'S NOT VOTING AND WILL HOLD
IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MADAM CHAIR YEAH TO.
ON ITEM.
FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY SEVEN WERE
ALL MY SHE DID DOESN'T MENTION
FIFTY THREE AS FOR MAKE SURE WE
INCLUDED HATCHET MITIGATION
PROGRAM WORK LOAD AND OTHER ACT
IN THE SAME.
FIFTY THREE YOU MAY HAVE SAID IT
I JUST IN HERE PROBABLY DID WILL
SAY.
.
FIFTY THREE HAZARD MITIGATION
PROGRAM WORKLOAD INCREASE WAS
MENTIONED. OF RECOVERY PROGRAM.
ITEM FIFTY FOR
FOR NO I WOULDN'T BUSY AS AN
ITEM MISSING IS EITHER
MEDICATION WORKLOAD INCREASE IS
ITEM FIFTY THREE. FIFTY FOUR IS
RECOVERY PROGRAM WHERE HE LOW
HAZARD.
FIFTY FIVE.
WE DIDN'T DO.
THE REGIONAL HAS IT OKAY WE WILL
VOTE ON ITEM FIFTY FIVE WHICH IS
REGIONAL HAS IT.
.
THE VOTE WAS FOUR ZERO SO WE
WILL PUT THAT IN AT WAS AN ADDED
ON TO THE SHEET THAT NUMBERS ALL
OF IT OFF THAT YOU HAD. SELIMIYE
READ THEM AGAIN TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE CLEAR WE'RE GOING TO DO
ITEM FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY SEVEN
AGAIN. UP FIFTY THREE IS A
HAZARD MITIGATION PROGRAM
WORKLOAD INCREASE.
FIFTY FOUR IS A RECOVERY PROGRAM
WORKLOAD INCREASE FIFTY FIVE IS
A REGIONAL HAS IT HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS RESPONSE PROGRAM.
FIFTY SIX IS A SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS AND COLLABORATION TWO
AND FIFTY SEVEN IS A DISASTER
SERVICE WORKERS VOLUNTEER
PROGRAM FLOW TAKE THOSE AGAIN
AND ALL TOGETHER ROLL CALL WEBER
HIGH JONES SAWYER AYE. LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR CATCHING THAT
THAT THOSE ALL OUT ON A FOUR OH
VOTE WITHOUT WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR. THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO VOTE
IF HE RETURNS THAT THEN BRINGS
US EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY MADAM
CHAIR I JUST. ON ISSUE OF
PROCEDURE PROCEDURE SINCE RARITY
VOTED ON THOSE BEFORE WE CAN
VOTE ON THEM AGAIN THAT WE HAVE
TO RECALL THE PRINT THE PREVIOUS
VOTE.
YEAH WE CAN HEALTHCARE WHICH IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO DO. IT
WE GET A MOTION TO RECALL THE
PREVIOUS VOTE MOTION OF THE
INITIAL FOR REMISSION ORDERED
IT.
INITIAL VOTE TO RECALL THE
INITIAL VOTE OKAY SO MOVED SO
MOVED.
OKAY ROLL CALL.
TO RECALL THAT WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
OKAY THEN THE THE EARLIER VOTERS
RECALL HIM WILL VOTE AGAIN ON
THIS TO MAKE SURE.
AT THIS TIME WILL VOTE AGAIN
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE FACED A KITCHENETTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SKY BRINGS US IN A HOME QUESTION
ON.
THE SHEET I HAD ITEM THIRTY ONE
THE SAN QUENTIN STATE PRISON NEW
BOILER FACILITY. WITH THAT.
OR YOU CAN.
YEAH WE DID THAT.
THOSE DELETED DIVES MODERATES
AND PALATABLE TO ME THAT CALLING
THE CENTRAL CENTER REPLACEMENT
HIS KITCHEN WEST.
HIS IS ON.
ELECTRONICALLY.
SO YOU HAVE ALL YOU LIKE TRONIC
COM
OKAY WE CAN UPDATE YOUR LATIMES
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
OKAY OF THAT THEN BRINGS US TO
THAT ITEM FOR HEARING TODAY
WHICH IS.
.
THE CDC R. JANITORIAL PROPOSAL
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO I THINK WE
HAVE A PANEL OF INDIVIDUALS. THE
JANET OF THE AGENDA ARE PROPOSED
REQUESTED AID NET AUGMENTATION
OF ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WHICH INCLUDES
A REDUCTION. OF TWELVE POINT
NINE MILLION ASSOCIATED WITH THE
EXISTING PRIDE CONTRACT AND AN
INCREASE OF THIRTEEN POINT ONE.
MILLION FOR CIVIL SERVICE STAFF
TO TAKE OVER THE GENITAL
SERVICES
THIS ASSUMES A RAMP UP IN HIRING
OVER THE COURSE.
THE MAY REVISION ADJUSTMENTS
CONTAINS TWO COMPONENTS FIRST
THERE IS A REQUEST FOR EIGHT
MILLION. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO RESTORE PARTIAL YOUR
FUNDING FOR THE PRIDE CONTRACT.
THE PLAN IS FOR THE CONTRACT TO
BE RAMPED UP OVER THE COURSE OF
THE BUDGET YEAR AS WE HIGHER
CIVIL SERVICE STAFF.
HOWEVER IN JANUARY THE CONTRACT
WAS INADVERTENTLY ZERO OUT
COMPLETELY THIS FUNDING WOULD
SIMPLY RESTORE THAT PARTIAL YOUR
PHASE OUT. FINALLY THE MAY
REVISION ADJUSTMENTS REALIZE
THAT CUT THE AUTHORITY FOR
CONTRACTING WITH PI EIGHT UNCLE
TO OVERSEE THE GENITAL SERVICES
AND CCR TO CORRECTIONAL HEALTH.
CARE SERVICES.
WE HAVE WITH US AS HE AYE YOU
ACTUALLY MARTINEZ PRIDE DON
NELSON. A DISABILITY RIGHTS.
CURTIS CHILD IN CDC ARE THE
RECEIVER.
THEY WILL COME FORWARD.
OKAY INTRODUCED.
OKAY
.
OKAY WE CAN BEGIN WITH ASHLEY
MARTINEZ.
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ACTUALLY
MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION LOCAL ONE THOUSAND.
WE REPRESENT OVER NINETY SIX
THOUSAND STATE EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING THE STATE'S CUSTODIANS
AND WE ARE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THE PLAN TO TRANSITION THE
WORKERS CURRENTLY UNDER THE
PRIDE CONTRACT BEGAN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AFTER THE
DEPARTMENT FOUND THAT THEY WERE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH SECTION
ONE NINE ONE THREE ZERO. OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE WHICH LAYS OUT
WHEN A DEPARTMENT OR STATE
AGENCY CAN ENTER INTO A CONTRACT
FOR PERSONAL SERVICES.
IN ORDER TO BECOME CLIP
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW THE
DEPARTMENT ESTABLISHED THE
TRANSITION PLAN WHICH IS LAID
TO MOVE ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES AND
THE STATE CIVIL SERVICE WHERE
THEY WOULD CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
COMPARABLE SALARIES.
FULL HEALTH BENEFITS AND A
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION PLAN
FROM THE STATE.
.
AS NOTED BY THE RECEIVER AT LAST
WEEK'S HEARING AND.
THOUGH PROBABLY TALK ABOUT IT
TODAY.
WORK CURRENTLY IN YEAR TWO OF
THAT TRANSITION.
AND IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THAT TRANSITION HAS ALREADY
BEGUN.
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND IS COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
THAT NO WORKERS DISPLACED DURING
THIS TRANSITION.
I WE FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THE
FAILURE TO APPROVE THIS PLAN AS
PROPOSED COULD
POTENTIALLY DISRUPT THE DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS OF THE FACILITY.
.
THEN PUT THE TRANSITION OF THE
EMPLOYEES AT RISK
AND WE DO NOT BELIEVE THIS WOULD
BE IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OR IN THE
BEST INTERESTS.
OF THE WORKERS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU THE LEGISLATURE THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THAT THIS.
TRANSITION IS SUCCESSFUL AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
STUDENT ALSO.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DON NELSON
VICE PRESIDENT OF OPERATIONS FOR
PRIDE INDUSTRIES.
PRIZE A NONPROFIT COMPANY.
FOUNDED IN THE BASEMENT CHURCH
IN AUBURN IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX
IN OUR MISSION IS TO EMPLOY
PEOPLE DISABILITIES.
AND WE START OUT THE.
STOCKTON PRISON CONTRACT
AND HAVE WORKED OUR WORK FORCE
TO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY NOT
EMPLOYEES WITH DISABILITIES.
THE ON THAT PROJECT WE'VE
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITIONED.
INSTITUTION THROUGH AN OFF OF IT
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
INSPECTION.
ACA AUDIT AND ALSO A JACO AUDIT
AND THE STATE AUDITOR'S AUDIT TO
TO RETURN THE FACILITY BACK TO A
HOSPITAL HEALTHCARE STANDARDS.
OF WHICH IT WASN'T PERFORMING
PRIOR.
NOT OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA R. EMPLOYS A DISABILITIES
WILL NOT HAVE THE SUPPORTS.
IN THE SYSTEMS IN A STRUCTURED
THAT WE PROVIDE.
UNDER OUR PRIDE INDUSTRIES A TO
PERFORM THE WORK.
IF THE TRANSITION OVER STATE
CIVIL SERVICE ON POSITIONS.
OKAY. ANYONE ELSE CURTIS CHILD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CARE CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND THAT INCLUDES.
FOR INCREASING MORE COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT.
LET ME JUST SAY AT THE OUTSET
ON ON THIS PROPOSAL.
WE ARE WE ARE OPPOSED BUT.
WE REALLY DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON WHETHER.
THIS.
IS THE EMPLOYMENT OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS IS THROUGH A CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYMENT OR IS AND
CONTINUED DUH WITH THE CONTRACT
WITH.
WITH PRIDE WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT IS ASSURING THAT THE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
CURRENTLY EMPLOYED DE IN THESE
POSITIONS BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN.
THOSE.
POSITIONS AND AND THERE IT
SPENT DISCUSSION ABOUT POTENTIAL
WAYS OF OF DOING THAT WHICH IS
INCLUDED DUH THE LISTS AND THE
LEAP PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T THINK
THAT THAT WILL INDEED ASSURE
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
ABLE TO.
KEEP THEIR EMPLOYMENT AND AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO CDC ARE.
AND GOING BACK AND LOOKING AT
THEIR NUMBERS ON THE.
THEIR EMPLOYMENT OF PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES SPENT QUITE
DISAPPOINTING.
IN IN THE PAST AND PARTICULARLY
USING THE ONLY PROGRAM TO.
TO GET TO THAT EMPLOYMENT.
WHAT WE WOULD ASK?
IS THE COMMITTEE LOOKED TO.
DOING IS ASSURING THAT THERE
WOULD BE SOME IF YOU MOVE
FORWARD.
WITH.
WITH THE.
BCP IS TO ASSURE THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT THERE IS SOME
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD SURE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT A CAP CAN
KEEP THEIR EMPLOYMENT SHOULD
THEY SO DESIRE.
AS.
CIVIL SERVICE.
IF THERE IF THERE IS A DESIRE
TO GO IN THE DIRECTION OF
RETAINING THE CONTRACT THEN I
THINK THAT ISSUE DOESN'T.
PRESENT ITSELF BUT EITHER WAY.
I THINK WE WOULD WANT TO SEE ON
A LANGUAGE THAT TO THATWOULD
ENSURE THEIR CONTINUED
EMPLOYMENT I JUST WANT TO ADD
ONE OTHER PIECE THAT I THINK IS
CRITICAL JUST TWO YEARS AGO.
WE HAD FINISHED UP WITH WITH
THE.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND DDS
AND AND DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION A BLUEPRINT FOR
THE EMPLOYMENT OF.
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES AND
WITH A CALL IN A DESIGN FOR
CALIFORNIA AND INCREASING
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AND WE THINK THIS
WOULD GO IN THAT DIRECTION THE
CONTRARY TO THAT THANK YOU.
SO IT THE RECEIVER SEE OUR
BUSINESS SEAT.
YEAH.
PUTTING HIM UNDER MINEAR ON THE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE POLICY
IN ADMIN FOURTH RECEIVERS DID.
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THE TRANSITION
PLAN OF PRIDE THE IMP IN PRY
CONTRACT TO CIVIL SERVICE.
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION ONE I
WANT THE RIO TELLS ME THAT I
NEED TO HIRE CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES. WHEN WE MADE THE
DECISION WHEN THE DECISION WAS
MADE THAT WE NEEDED TO MOVE IN
THIS DIRECTION.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
JANUARY OR SO WE'VE BEEN DOING
LOT OF ACTIVITY TO TRY TO.
ASSIST THE PRIDE EMPLOYEES IN A
CURRENT OBTAINING OF THE ABILITY
TO GET ON THE CERTIFICATION LIST
SO THAT WE CAN THEN TURN THEM
INTO CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES.
I DON'T KNOW OF ANOTHER WAY THAT
I CAN GET THEM TO BECOME CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYEES WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS. OUT OF A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
CUSTODIANS THAT THEY HAVE WE'VE
GOTTEN NINETY ON THIS.
THE CERTAIN LIST SO THAT'S
FIFTY ONE PERCENT OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES IS ON THE LIST. WE
HAVE A PHASED ROLLOUT OF FOR THE
POSITIONS SO JANUARY THEIR
POSITIONS THAT COME ON IT'S
ABOUT FOURTEEN THOSE POSITIONS
HAVE BEEN FIELD ONE THIS WITH. A
PRIDE EMPLOYEE.
WE HAVE ABOUT FORTY SEVEN TO
FORTY EIGHT POSITIONS THAT COME
ON IN SEPTEMBER. I THINK IT'S
NOVEMBER DECEMBER IT'S LIKE
FORWARD.
FOR THREE THREE ADDITIONAL
PRAISE THAT SINCE ABOUT FORTY
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT POSITIONS
WITH THAT MANY PRIDE EMPLOYEES
ON THE LIST.
THE HOPE IS THAT SOME OF THOSE
PRIDE EMPLOYEES GET PICKED UP TO
BE CALM CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES.
AND SO THE THAT.
PROBLEM LIES IN THE FACT THAT
THEY WANT ME TO DO SOMETHING
THAT I DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DO I HAVE TO GO WITH CIVIL
SERVANTS THAT'S WHAT. THEY WANT
THEY ASK.
WHEN I SAY THEY ITS PRIDE OKAY
OKAY. IN THE DISABILITY VITAMIN.
THAT'S WHO I'M SPEAKING ABOUT
BUT THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO
WITH THAT I HAVE TO GO WITH THE
PROCESS IN THE PROCESS FILLS ME
I HAVE TO GO THROUGH CIVIL
SERVICE.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WE HELD EVENTS AT THE CH
C. F. SPECIFICALLY WE TOOK
COMPUTERS THEY ARE FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WE'VE DONE A NUMBER
OF CAMPAIGNS. THEY'RE TRYING TO
GET.
THEIR EMPLOYEES ON THE
CERTIFICATION LIST BECAUSE
THAT'S THEIR PATH TO BECOMING
CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES.
AND WE'VE GOT A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL EVENTS THAT WE'VE
BEEN HOLDING UP AS A CONSEQUENCE
WE GOT A LOT OF CANDIDATES ON
THE LIST SO WE'VE YOU KNOW PUT
SOME ATTENTION AND SOME FOCUS ON
IT. WITH THAT RECRUITMENT EFFORT
AND SO THEREIN LIES THE PROBLEM
I'M DOING WHAT I THEY'RE DOING
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO GET THEM
ON THE LIST TO GET THEM A PATH.
TO BECOME CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES AND I DON'T HAVE TOO
MUCH OF ANY OTHER THING THAT I
CAN DO TO ASSIST THEM. EXCEPT
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AND LIKE I
SAY WE'VE GOT LIKE NINETY ARE
ALMOST FIFTY ONE PERCENT OF
THEIR.
STAFF ON THE CERTIFICATION LIST.
SO YOU'VE YOU'VE BEEN.
.
SO SEWING IT I THINK THERE WAS
SOME CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT WE
WERE TRYING TO DO A WHAT WAS
GOING ON SO ONE MAKE SURE THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE HOW
MANY INDIVIDUALS AND PRIDE THAT
ARE. CURRENTLY IN THE KNOW.
WORKING IN THE FACILITY HOW MANY
OTHER.
THE FACILITY I THINK THERE'S
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
OR SO READ ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN EMPLOYEES THERE.
CURRENTLY A OF THAT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES PERFORMING ON THAT
PROJECT ALSO YET SO OUT OF THE
TWO SEVENTY THAT'S A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN SKIS ME. AND.
AND HUNDRED AND TWENTY ARE.
BASICALLY PRIDE EMPLOYEES THERE
OUGHT LAW THE ALL TOO SEVENTEEN
ARE PRIDE EMPLOYEES OKAY OF THAT
TO SEVENTEEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
OR EMPLOYEES WITH DISABILITIES
OKAY OKAY SO THAT ARE THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES DISABILITIES ABOVE AND
BEYOND EIGHTY A OKAY SO. WHERE
ACCOMMODATIONS ARE MADE THAT ARE
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT EIGHTY
EIGHT FIRES RIGHT?
SO WE PROVIDE COUNSELING AND
SUPPORTS NAM DAY MAKE THEM
SUCCESSFUL ON THE JOB OKAY AND
YOU SAY THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CERTIFY HOW MANY OF THEM. WHAT
WHAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED IS THAT
THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX?
IN THE CUSTODIAN SERIES RIGHT
AND.
OUT OF THOSE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX WE'VE GOT NINETY PEOPLE ON
THE CERTIFICATION WILL IT.
SUB THAT'S ABOUT FIFTY ONE
PERCENT OF THEIR TOTAL
CUSTODIANS THAT THEY HAD MOVED
TO I'M NOT CLEAR ABOUT HOW MANY
OF THOSE ARE WERE THE ONES THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE WHAT TWENTY
ONE THAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT OR
IF THE ONE TWENTY ONE THAT HE'S
SPEAKING THAT IS ALL CUSTODIAN
CLASSIFICATIONS BECAUSE HE DOES
HAVE DIFFERENT CLASSIFICATIONS
THERE SO I'M NOT CLEAR ABOUT
THAT HERE THAT ONE TWENTY FALLS
WITHIN A COUPLE CLASSIFICATIONS
BUT. ABOVE ALL OF OUR WORKFORCE
OUT THERE.
TO ONE TWENTY OUR EMPLOYEES A
DISABILITIES WHETHER THEY'RE
CUSTODIANS ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICE
TECHNICIANS OR FLOOR
TECHNICIANS.
IN IN UPPER LEVEL POSITIONS.
IF THEY MOVED UP AND IN BEEN
PROMOTED.
SO IN THIS IN THIS ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE HERE FOR THIS TRANSITION
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS I MEAN
BECAUSE YOU GOT ALL THESE
DIFFERENT CLASSIFICATIONS AND
AND YOU'RE MAKING A IF YOU'RE
MAKING THE CHANGE TO?
TO MOVE THEM INTO I GUESS INTO
TO CIVIL SERVICE IF YOU CAN.
I'M NOT MAKING THE CHANGE TO
MOVE THEM INTO CIVIL SERVICE
WHAT I'M DOING IS GOING TO GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET ON.
THE CERTIFICATION LIST SO THAT
THEY HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
BECOME CIVIL SERVANT ANGLO OKAY
YEAH HOW DOES AND WHAT IS
REQUIRED ON THAT IS THERE
TESTING YES RAINY HOPE THERE'S A
TEST PROCESS THAT DIDN'T
PROCESS.
AND WHAT WE DID IS WE HELD
RECRUITMENT EVENTS WHERE WE.
SET UP COMPUTERS FOR THEM AND IF
I DIDN'T THEM WITH LOGGING INTO
THE SYSTEM TO DO THE APPLICATION
AND TO GET THE A. TO GAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET ON THE
CERTIFICATION LIMITS
AND WE DON'T AN ACCORD IT WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY. OF YOUR
MEMBERS ARE DISABLED THAT ARE ON
THAT ARE CUSTODIANS WE DON'T
KNOW THAT. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
OF OUR DISABLED OF THE ONE
TWENTY I HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS TO APPLY I DON'T HAVE
THE NUMBERS ON THAT ARE. YOU
KNOW WE WERE NOT TRACKING YOU
KNOW WHO'S DOING APPLICATIONS
AND HAS NOT. TO DO YOU HAVE NO
MEMORY DON'T HAVE THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL I DO NOT KNOW YES.
AND THIS THIS TRANSITION IS TO
CURE OCCUR WHEN. JULY FIRES
OH. OKAY YES MA'AM THIS IS THE
LAST YEAR OF THE DELIVERY YEAR
TRANSITION.
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING. FOR
SOMETIME OKAY WE'VE KNOWN ABOUT
IT FOR SOME TIME
SO MOST OF THE TRANSITION HAS
OCCUR.
WHEN WE SAY THAT NOW AND FOR THE
TRANSITION PRIDE IS DOING THE
SERVICE. UP UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH%
JUNE THIRTIETH.
SEVEN ONE THERE IS A PHASED IN
APPROACH TO TRANSITIONING PRIDE
OUT OF PROVIDING THE SERVICES
AND CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES
PROVIDING THE SERVICES.
SO EFFECTIVE.
JULY FIRST THERE'S ABOUT
FOURTEEN POSITIONS THAT COME
ALIVE WE'VE ALREADY DONE THAT.
INTERVIEW PROCESS WE'VE GOT
COMMITMENTS. INDIVIDUALS TO COME
ON JULY FIRES THE NETS ROLLOUT
PHASE IT'S SEPTEMBER OKAY THIS
YEAR SO SLOWLY BUT SURELY YOU'RE
BASICALLY REPLACING THEM WITH
CIVIL SERVICE YES OKAY. AND.
AND EVERYONE I ASSUME IS
APPLYING FOR THOSE POSITIONS AT
NO FOLKS THAT.
WE'RE JUST MOVING AND EVERYONE
IS APPLYING FOR ONE OF THE
POSITIONS THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
WE'RE HAVING CONDUCTING
INTERVIEW PROCESS GOING THROUGH
THE INTERVIEW PROCESS
COMPETITIVE PROCESS. CONDUCTING
INTERVIEWS TO FILL THOSE
VACANCIES.
OKAY.
I ASSUME IT IT IS A LITTLE I'M
NOT SO I GUESS THE CONCERN IS
THAT WE WERE MOVING A NUMBER OF
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS OUT OF
THOSE POSITIONS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY BUT THAT
WAS A CONCERN. AND FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S.
THAT THAT HAS TO OCCUR A LEASE
THE TRANSITION TO CIVIL SERVICE.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
PROGRAM THAT WOULD BASICALLY
ALLOW THESE INDIVIDUALS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK.
BUT. THE ONE OF THE. PROBLEM TO
ME BECOMES THIS
THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT TRYING TO
GRANDFATHER THEM FROM CONTRACT
EMPLOYEES INTO CIVIL SERVANT
OKAY THERE'S NO MECHANISM THAT
I'M AWARE OF THAT TRANSITIONS
THEM FROM A CONTRACT EMPLOYEE TO
CIVIL SERVICE AND. THEY HAVE TO
COMPETE LIKE EVERYONE ELSE DOES
THE GAY CIVIL SERVICE STATUS
IT'S A COMPETITIVE PROCESS.
THERE IS A LEAP EXAMINATION
LIMITED.
EXAMINATION APPOINTMENT PROCESS
YOU'RE PROBABLY IT WHERE IT
DIDN'T AND WE DID ESTABLISH A.
OF.
EXAM FOR THE CUSTODIANS WITH
THE CORRECTIONAL FACILITY MONICA
TO IT BECAUSE THAT'S THE SAFETY
DESIGNATION THAT COMES WITH IT
WHEN I ASKED MY STAFF TO LOOK AT
THAT LIST IT APPEARS THAT MOST
OF THE PEOPLE. THERE'S ABOUT
TWELVE.
TWELVE UPRIGHTS PEOPLE ON THE
LEAP FROM THIS BUT THEIR OWN
BELIEF LIST THAT'S NON CF SO I
ASKED THEM TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO ENSURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE TO GET ON
THE ONE WITH THE CF DESIGNATION
IN ORDER TO WORK FOR US BECAUSE.
THAT IS THE LEAD LISTS WE WOULD
YOU KNOW WHAT A SEA OF
DESIGNATION IT'S CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY. AT THE SITE AT THE
FOUR REQUIREMENTS OKAY I'M GOING
HOME.
DID YOU HAVE THEM MADAM CHAIR IF
I MIGHT.
JUST A COUPLE OF POINTS I THINK
THAT TED NOT TO TO COMPLICATE
THIS BUT. CERTAINLY THE OFFER OF
A PLACE ON THE LIST DOES NOT
ASSURE THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL WILL
BE ABLE TO BE EMPLOYED.
EITHER THROUGH LEAP OR
OTHERWISE AND AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT THE LIST HAS.
.
THOSE WHO ARE APPLYING FOR THIS
JOB THAT ARE NOT INDIVIDUALS
WHO.
CURRENTLY ARE EMPLOYED IN THE
POSITION WHERE F..
WITH PRIDE RIGHT NOW.
SO THERE IS.
I THINK IT'S SIGNIFICANT CHANCE
AND AGAIN LOOKING A BIT TO
HISTORY THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE NOT ALL GOING TO BE PICKED
UP OR EVEN IF THEY DO THEY MAY
THERE MAY BE SOME SIGNIFICANT
GAP.
IN BETWEEN THE.
DATE OF TERMINATION AND AND IF
THEY MAKE THEIR WAY.
UP ON THE LIST THE OTHER THING
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT WHAT
PRIDE PROVIDES.
FOR MANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS AS
JOB COACHING
AND SO THERE'S AT LEAST THREE I
THINK POSITIONS FOR. JOB
COACHES.
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
ISN'T SUCH A.
A.
CLASSIFICATION FOR A POSITION
THERE SO INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY BE
IN NEED OF JOB COACHING TO
COMPLETE THEIR.
JOBS WOULD NOT BE AND BE ABLE
TO.
BE.
EMPLOYED IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THOSE SAME KIND OF SUPPORT
SO SUPPORTS THAT HELPS THEM.
GETTING TO WORK IF THERE ARE
PUSH CERTAIN PROBLEMS WITH THE
JOB.
PRIDE CAN CERTAINLY SPEAK
BETTER THAN I BUT BUT THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF FUNCTION. THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE NOW
PROVIDING TO KEEP THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EMPLOYED. THAT YOU WOULD LOSE
AND I THINK.
THEY WOULD NOT AT ALL HAVETHE
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH LIST OR
OTHERWISE TO CONTINUE THAT.
.
THEIR EMPLOYMENT I THINK THESE
ARE ALL INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
BEEN EMPLOYED OVER SIX MONTHS.
FOR THE POSITION THEY'RE WELL
TRAINED THEY'RE QUALIFIED
THEY'RE DOING THE JOB.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
VIETNAM.
WE WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN PARTICULARLY FOR THIS GROUP
THAT IS NOW WORKING WITHIN.
THE FACILITIES TO KEEP THEM
EMPLOYED.
YOU HAVE ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE
OF THE TESTIMONY IN THE
AUDIENCE.
THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE PROPOSAL.
IS THE TURN IT OFF ALRIGHT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
WHERE A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
OF THIS PROPOSAL AT ONE ADELINE
MACINNES OF THOSE SERVICE YEAH
YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS IS?
THE FINAL STAGE OF A TRANSITION
PLAN THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS SKINNER.
CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS WHERE
THEY'LL HAVE.
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER BENEFITS
WOULD HAVE A PENSION WHERE THEY
HAVE CONFERENCE. HERE WE BELIEVE
THAT.
THE STEEP REALLY PROGRAM AND
OTHER INITIATIVES CAN A USE
THOSE TOOLS TO BUY EIGHTEEN TO
WORK IN A MITIGATING ANY ISSUES
WITH A TRANSITION WORKERS OVER
ITS OF THE PARTICULARLY WORKERS
WITH WITH DISABILITIES AND ALSO.
AS OUR POSITION THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT BILLIARDS WERE FIELDING TO
PROVIDE THE FUNDS TO COMPLETE
THE TRANSITION WOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE ENSIGNS IT
CONSEQUENCES BUT WORKERS IN THE
FACILITIES OF SOME.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME VERSION
OF WHAT I THINK YOU I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WERE NAY BAYARDO SLU CALIFORNIA
WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
LABOR FED. HOME IN SUPPORT OF
THE PCB.
THANK YOU OR ANYONE.
THE POST THE PROPOSAL.
VENTURE MEMBERS BOB JEREMY HAVE
THE NATIONAL UNION HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AND. I THINK EVERYBODY
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE KINDA
DANCED AROUND THE ISSUE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ADULTS AND
HAVE FUNCTIONING AUTISM.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ADULTS THAT
HAVE DOWN SYNDROME WE'RE TALKING
BASICALLY THE ONLY REASON THAT
THE RECEIVER SAID THAT'S CORRECT
THEIR FIFTY ONE PEOPLE OF THE
WORK OR FIFTY ONE PERCENT. HAS
BEEN ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR THE
LIST THE REST OF THEM CAN'T PASS
THE TEST MADAM CHAIR AND THAT'S
THE ISSUE.
THAT'S THAT'S WHO THEY WANT TO
PUT OUT OF WORK OR PEOPLE WHO
ARE DISABLED WHO HAVE JOBS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULDN'T BE WORKING
THAT CAN'T PASS THE CIVIL
SERVICE EXAM.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE. THAT'S WHAT
THE RECEIVER IS IMPLYING SHE
CAN'T TAKE CARE OF.
SHE CAN'T MAKE A TEST THAT THEY
CAN PASS
SO THAT'S THE ISSUE.
WHO?
YEAH.
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS.
ANTHONY GRANT AND I AM A FLOOR
FOR PERSONS FOR PRIDE
INDUSTRIES.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH PRIDE
SEND SINCE SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
I'VE ACTUALLY LOOKED TO. BE.
LEAP PROGRAM TRYING TO GO
THROUGH IT BUT.
.
I DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND ON HOW
THE WHOLE PROCESS WORKS FOR
LEAVE.
AND EVEN THOUGH I CAN LOOK AT
THAT TEST THE.
AND BE ABLE TO TAKE IT.
I HAVE A I STRUGGLE WITH THE
INTERVIEWS BECAUSE MY AUTISM.
AND.
SO IT IS REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
ME TO.
DO INTERVIEWS WITH PEOPLE.
AND I'VE A AYE BUT OUR OWN AND
BEFORE I HAD PRIDE I WAS OUT OF
WORK FOR OVER THREE YEARS.
APPLIED FOR HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
I CAN'T EVEN GET A JOB BUT.
TARGET OR WALMART.
AND I'D BEEN THERE FOR A AND FOR
A LONG TIME.
BECAUSE I FELT LIKE I WAS
WORTHLESS.
AND COMPLETELY USELESS HAD
ANYONE TO LIVE.
A PRIDE GAVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THINGS THAT.
I COULD NOT HAVE EVEN DREAMED
OF.
AND. WITHOUT THIS JOB. I'M
PRETTY SURE I WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO STAND HERE TODAY AND ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF OF MY FULL OF PRIDE
FAMILY.
THANK YOU.
HI UM. MY NAME IS MAIN I'M
UNEMPLOYED FOR PRANGE FREE.
I'M A FLOOR FOR PERSON CONSIDERS
IT CUSTODIAN LEAD.
.
I'M A VISUAL IMPAIRED SO.
BEFORE I JUST LOOK FOR JOBS I
CONFIDE JOB BECAUSE OF MY VISUAL
IMPAIR BUT NOW THAT I'VE FOUND
PRY.
PART AS A COMEDY MEAN. AND SUCH
AS FOR MY VISION LIKE IN THE
MORNING IF I CAN DRIVE TO WAKE
AT.
.
THEY WOULD ALLOW ME TO WAIT
UNTIL LOW PAID.
PAY LIKE INTO. THE NEVER COME
TO WORK ALSO. WENT TIME CHANGES
AROUND.
WINTERTIME.
I WOULD ACTUALLY THEY WILL CALM
ME ME LET ME GET OFF EARLY AND
NAM COME. COME HOME SO THAT YOU
KNOW.
IT WILL BE EASY FOR ME.
.
PRIDE IS OPEN UP THE GATE AND
DOOR FOR ME TO AND I HOPE THAT.
PRY COULD BE MY KOREAN GOAL IN
THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR GUYS TIME TODAY.
FROM MY IS MICHAEL GORDON AND I
WASN'T BORN WITH THE DISEASE.
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO I ARE MY
ARMENIA OF GOING DOWN SO I'D
ALWAYS WORKED.
BR WHEN I WAS YOUNG BECAUSE I'M
FROM OUR.
VERY DYSFUNCTIONAL HOME I WAS
ABUSED BUT MARS PROCHAIN. HOW TO
SELL DRUGS WHEN I WAS YOUNGER MY
MOM WOULD PAY THE BILL SALAS
FROM A VERY ROUGH?
UPBRINGING.
AND ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO AYE YOU
IN UP HERE UC DAVIS. AND THEY
TOLD ME OUT MICHAEL YOU HAVE.
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE NOT SURE
WHAT'S GOING ON. BUT YOU
LITERALLY HAVE HOLES IN HER
SPINAL CORD AND AT THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS OLDER SO YOU'RE NEVER
GONNA WORK AGAIN.
UNLIKE WHAT YOU MEAN AND.
AS I WAS GROWING UP I WOULD
ALWAYS LOSE MY JOB BECAUSE I'M
ALWAYS HAD A LOT OF BACK PAIN
SHOULDER PAIN. SO I WASN'T ABLE
TO ALWAYS WORK BUT I'M I JUST
THOUGHT OKAY WELL MAYBE IS
BECAUSE MY MAYBE MY UPBRINGING
WHATEVER THIS AND THAT.
BUT MATTER WHAT I WILL LOSE A
JOB I GO YOU KNOW THE WHEN I
LOSE A JOB LIKE DON'T YOU KNOW
WHEN TO STOP I COULDN'T WORK ACT
DAY IF I COULD NEVER DO THE
FORTY HOUR WORK WEEK SECOND
EVERY THIS NEVER DO THAT.
BUT THEN ALSO ONE OF MY BUDDIES
I'VE BEEN WITH PRIOR NOW ABOUT
SIX MONTHS BUT. THIS IS THE
FIRST ALLEN HAD SINCE I'VE BEEN
DISABLED.
I WOULD MIGHT MY KIDS I HAVE
FOUR CHILDREN A WIFE AT HOME.
BUT MY LIVING ROOM WHEN I FIRST
GOT DISABLED I WASN'T WORKING I
WOULD HAVE TO CUT MY SON'S
BOXERS.
BECAUSE I WASN'T EVEN ABLE TO
BUY AND UNDERWEAR. THERE DIE I
COULDN'T NO ONE WOULD HIRE ME
WHEN I WAS WALKING A WALKER
WALKING AND. WALKING WITH A CANE
TRY TO GO TO WALMART SAYING HERE
ALL THIS GRIEF FOR YOU GUYS.
AUSTIN AUSTIN WATCHER DISCREET.
BUT DEBT DEL YEAH THEY'RE
INTERVIEW. ANYBODY'S GONNA
INTERVIEW BUT THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO HIRE YOU.
AND THEN AND AND UNLOCKING NO
DISRESPECT MA'AM BUT.
PRIDE PAYS US.
A DECENT AMOUNT YOU GUYS ARE
WILLING TO PAY US FOR DOLLARS
LESSEN OUR THAT'S WHY I'M NOT
GOING TO THE TEST.
DATE THEY'RE GONNA THEY'RE
OFFERED US FOUR DOLLARS LESS TO
DO THE SAME JOB. WOULD YOU TAKE
IT.
I'M NOT GOOD AT STATE AND
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE BEING HONEST.
THAT'S WHY THE OTHER FORTY NINE
OR FIFTY PERCENT THAT'S WHY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO THE TEST.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT WILLING TO GO
PICK FOUR DOLLARS LESSEN OUR HOW
MY GOING TO. PROVIDE FOR MY
FAMILY AND I'M NOT GOING TO GET
ALL THAT BOND IS GOING TO GET
IN.
FOR ONCE IN FIVE YEARS.
I FEEL LIKE I'M NORMAL TO GET
BECAUSE WHEN I GO TO WORK.
THAT'S HOW THEY MAKE ME FEEL I
CAN'T WORK EIGHT HOURS.
WHAT COMPANIES GONNA HIRE ME LET
ME GO TO WORK FOR FIVE HOURS OR
EVEN IF I MET FIVE HOURS?
A JOB COACH RIGHT HERE WAS
MICHAEL HOW YOU FEEL WITH A
EVERY DAY.
DON'T.
I WANT YOU
OKAY.
CAN'T GO HOME
EVEN IF IT'S THREE HOURS
THEY ALLOW ME TO WORK TO REALITY
AND GO HOME.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE PAIN AND.
I DON'T KNOW OF ANY.
TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR BUT ALSO THE
COMMITTEE HOW MUCH OUR COACH A
PRIDE INJURIES.
WHAT I DO IS APPROVE OR A
PROVIDE SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
EMPLOYEES WITH DISABILITIES?
DEATH TAXES IT WOULD JUST
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT PHYSICAL SPORT
NAM EVEN DISTRAUGHT SUPPORT.
ARMS OF OUR EMPLOYEES HAVE
COGNITIVE DISABILITIES AND WHAT
I DO IS I CAN GO WHEN AND.
IF SOMEBODY'S FOR HIM TO STEP
ALL GOING TO SAY HEY NO LESS
MEMBER WE DO IT THIS WAY WE DO
IT THIS WAY WE DO THAT. APPROVAL
AT PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES IN THE MORNINGS A HOME.
WE HAVE SEVERAL EMPLOYEES TO
TAKE THE CITY BUS IN THE MORNING
AND DID SOME OF THEM LEAVE. FOR
FORTY FIVE TO GET TO WORK AT SIX
THIRTY.
I'M THERE IN THE MORNING FIVE
THIRTY BREITNER REALLY PICKED UP
EVERYBODY FROM WORK IN THE
MORNING.
ILLIQUIDITY.
BEFORE SORT OF THIS JOB.
I NEVER REALLY UNDERSTOOD WHAT
STUPID PLAY WITH A DISABILITY
WAS I DON'T START MAY BE FISCAL
WHATEVER WAS BUT.
OUR EMPLOYEES ARE CAPABLE.
PEOPLE DOING WHAT THEY CAN AND
DATE ARE VERY BRIGHT.
.
I DON'T THINK THAT WILL BE
SUPPORTED WITH THIS TRANSITION.
WITH ALL THE SUPPORT THAT WE
PROVIDE FOR ARM ARE PLEASE WITH
DISABILITIES.
SO I EMPLOYEE GOSTOSA PLEASE
THINK ABOUT THAT THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WEBER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
RECALLING TRIPS SENDING ARCA
DISSOCIATION REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES THAT WE'RE HERE I IN
SUPPORT OF THE EFFORTS OF
PRIVATE INDUSTRIES. AS MANY OF
YOU ARE AWARE. EMPLOYMENT OF
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
HIS IS A ABYSMAL ON WE HAD ON
OUR NEVER NEVER A.
REACHING CLOSE TO OUR GOALS OF.
TRYING TO US SUPPORT HIM TO KEEP
UP PEOPLE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES EMPLOYED OF THIS IS
A STEP BACKWARDS AND AGAIN WE
SUPPORT. OUR ARE GOOD PROVIDER
AT TO ALTER REGIONAL CENTER
UPRIGHT INDUSTRIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THEY COME IT'S A QUESTION FOR
THOSE HERE DANCE LACKEY.
YEAH.
I JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT SO I
CERTAINLY DON'T THINK THAT THIS
IS AN INTENTIONAL ATTACK AGAINST
PRIDE INDUSTRIES BUT IT IS THAT.
WE HAVE.
IT'S VERY REGRETTABLE WHAT'S
BEING CONSIDERED.
WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE PROVEN TO BE.
PRODUCTIVE.
AND CAPABLE.
AND BECAUSE OF A POLITICAL.
TAKEOVER.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE UNEMPLOYED.
AND REALLY NOT COMPETITIVE. IN
ANY OTHER ATMOSPHERE.
AND I JUST THINK THAT THAT
SHOULD BE.
UNSAVORY TO THOSE OF US WHO ARE
POLICYMAKERS.
.
AS A A PERSON WHO.
BELIEVES VERY STRONGLY IN
ADVOCATING FOR THOSE WHO CAN
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES.
WE HAVE KNOW GREATER CALLING AS
PUBLIC SERVANTS.
TO STAND IN DEFENCE.
AND A FIGHT FOR THOSE WHO CAN'T
FIND FOR THEMSELVES AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE HERE.
AND SO I HOPE WE CAN COME TO A
REASONABLE SOLUTION I THINK
THAT.
THERE IS A WAY TO SYNTHESIZE.
LABOR.
AND THESE THESE UNIQUE WORKERS.
AND IF WE CAN'T DO THAT SHAME ON
US.
ANYONE ELSE.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. ARM.
YOU KNOW I HAVE A.
THIS IS.
I'M UNIQUELY QUALIFIED LOT OF
WAYS.
TO SPEAK HONEST.
ON ONE.
.
S. FORMER SEIU THREE FORTY SEVEN
MEMBER BEFORE BECAME SEVEN TWO
ONE WE UNDERTOOK.
BOMB AND ANALYSIS A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS WOULD. THEN REPUBLICAN
MAYOR RICHARD RIORDAN TO SEE
WHETHER NOT CONTRACTING OUT WAS
BETTER THAN USING INSIDE.
INDIVIDUALS ONE YOU COMPARE
APPLES TO APPLES.
GOVERNMENT PLOYS OUTSHINED
ON PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYEES.
EVERY TIME IN EVERY SECTOR. AS
AN A MAIN REASON FOR IT.
COINCIDENTLY FOR BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A LOT OF PRIDE.
AND WHAT THEY WERE DOING YOU'RE
PROUD TO BE A CITY EMPLOYEE TO
PROUD.
TO GET A PENSION PROUD TO GO TO
WORK EVERYDAY AND SO THEY WORK
EXTRA HARD.
IN A LOT OF OUR BUILDINGS
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
CLEAN SENATOR IN SAFE.
AND AND SO AS WE WENT THROUGH
THAT PROCESS WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVE.
TO THAT.
THAT MAYOR WHO WANTED TO
CONTRACT EVERYTHING OUT.
THAT SEIU.
EMPLOYEES MOSTLY CONSULTANT.
WHERE THE BEST
CHOICE AS FAR AS?
CONTRACTING.
THIS SECOND PARTS A LITTLE MORE.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO HELP YOU.
WITH THAT BECAUSE WE ALSO
TRANSITION I'VE INVOLVING
TRANSITIONING.
I'M FROM PRIVATE SECTOR
CUSTODIAL.
A CONTRACT
AND BRANCHING OUT TO MORE PUBLIC
SECTOR SO HAD THAT ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL CIVILLY.
EXPERIENCE AND IF I WOULD LOVE
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT.
TOO MUCH WHICH IS PROBABLY.
.
CLOSER TO MY HEART
ITEM.
AND I'VE SAID A COUPLE TIMES.
I WAS YOUNG.
HE WAS TOLD FOR THAT WE COULD
BRING HIS SAN AYE DOG. TO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL BECAUSE THE
SCHOOL DID NOT A COMEDY THAT.
OH MY BROTHER BEING.
A LITTLE REBELLIOUS SET FROM THE
PRINCIPAL OFFICE UNTIL
DEPRESSION EVERYBODY CAME. AND
NOW IN DC SCHOOL SYSTEM BAILOUT.
YOU TO BRING YOUR SYNAGOGUE.
BUT WE HAD TO PUSH IT.
WE HAD A PUSHY WHEN HE WASN'T.
MIDDLE SCHOOL WITH THE PUSH
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR HIM FOR
BRAILLE WHEN HE WASN'T.
IN HIGH SCHOOL TO DO DO IT WHEN
HE WAS IN COLLEGE.
AND EVEN TODAY MY BROTHER WHO'S
DOCTOR FREDRIC CLIFFORD JONES.
WHO THE VICE PRINCIPAL AND THE
DC SCHOOL DISTRICT?
SOMETIMES COME TO WORK LATE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO TAKE THE
BUS.
OBVIOUSLY HE DOESN'T DRIVE.
AND BEFORE UBER AND LEFT HE
WOULD TAKE THE BUS ANY WILL GET
WRITTEN UP SOMETIME FOR BEING
LATE BECAUSE BUSES ARE ALWAYS ON
TIME. ANY COULD STAY LATE.
SO HE'D AGAIN PUT HIS FOOT DOWN
AND MADE TO DC SCHOOLS.
DISTRICT.
ACCOMMODATE HIM.
SO THE HE'D BE ABLE TO TO DO ITS
WORK.
I THINK. WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
IS THE SAME THING THAT I'VE SEEN
ALL ALONG MY BROTHER'S LIFE
THAT.
WE WANNA HELP BUT I HANDS MIGHT
BE TIED.
AND IF IT IF IT TAKES.
AND I KNOW AT THE END OF OUR.
SESSION AND BUILD WITH IT TAKES
A BILL.
TO GIVE YOU THE FLEXIBILITY.
TO BE ABLE TO BRING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND TO THE SYSTEM.
SO THAT THEY CAN THEY CAN DO THE
WORK ESPECIALLY IF YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY CAN DO ALREADY. AND TO
BRING THE MEN.
I AM MORE WILLING.
TO WORK WITH A GOOD DEPARTMENT.
OR WITH ANYONE UMP TO TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
IT IS DEFINITELY NOT EASY
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
MAYBE THE SYSTEM IS A ROBUST
ENOUGH RIGHT NOW.
TUTOR TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN BUT BE
EXAMPLES ALREADY A SOUND LIKE
PRIDE IS ALREADY WORKED ON THAT.
OF HOW WE CAN.
WE COULDN'T IT WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE THAT.
AND ALSO. MAKE SURE THEY'RE AT
LEAST UP TO A CERTAIN
PROFICIENCY. WITH ADDITIONAL
TRAINING AND HELP ON BUT THAT'S.
MISTER LACKEY SAID THAT'S KINDA
ROLE OF GOVERNMENT IN.
IN THAT WHAT WE TRY TO TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR DO ALL THE TIME.
SHOULDN'T WE.
BE DOING THAT TOO AND SHOULDN'T
WE. AND I SAY WE JUST APPEAR
LAWMAKERS AND ADMINISTRATORS.
WE SHOULD FIGURE OUT A WAY.
THAT WE CAN BRING IN AS MANY AS
POSSIBLE ON KNOCKED ST IT IS
POSSIBLY YOU KNOW ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT BUT WE SHOULD.
COME UP WITH THE PLAN EARLY%
SEPARATE DISCUSSION WITH THEM.
AMERICAN DISABILITIES ACT
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO THIS ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
AND EXCITING HERE ANY DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW.
WE CAN WORK WITH EXPERTS ON THIS
ON SO THAT WE CAN BRING IT IS IN
MANY. POSSIBLE.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT.
.
AND I I KNOW WE ALREADY HAVE A A
BUDGET FOR THIS.
BUT IF WE EVER GONNA COMEDY AND
WE BELIEVE IN IT. IF WE NEED TO
INCREASED THIS BUDGET SO THAT WE
CAN ACCOMMODATE. INDIVIDUALS
LET'S DO THAT ABOUT THE DISHES A
GREAT IDEA A GREAT IDEA AND THAT
NOT ONLY DO YOU.
YOU GET MORE PEOPLE IN THE CIVIL
SERVICE.
BUT YOU'RE INCORPORATING PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WHICH I
HAVEN'T SEEN.
AND THE GOVERNMENT OF A LOT AND
SO I THINK YOU ALSO HAVE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE THE BOILERPLATE BUT TO BE
THE STANDARD BEARER OF HOW.
WE BLEND BOTH WHAT ARE CIVIL
SERVICE RULES AND REGULATIONS
AND AND I DON'T AND I WOULD LOVE
TO SIT WITH YOU AND.
I'VE TAKEN MORE CIVIL SERVICE
TEST LAW ALLOWS WHY I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THEM. FARE
FAMILIAR CIVIL SERVICE RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
I'M BUT I ALSO KNOW ABOUT
ACCOMMODATION.
BECAUSE I HAD TO MAKE
ACCOMMODATIONS AND.
OVER NINE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
CITY FACILITIES. HOME WHAT THE.
WITH A STAFF OF ABOUT. ON OVER A
THOUSAND AND NOT ALL OF THEM.
WE'RE FULLY ABLE.
AND WE WE WERE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE IN THE CITY OF LA.
WASN'T EASY.
BUT SINCE WE WANTED TO DO IT.
WE'RE ABLE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
SO ON. BOTH FRONTS
AS FAR AS.
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE BEST
QUALIFIED CIVIL SERVANTS WORKING
AND DOING A GREAT JOB.
TAKING OVER THOSE POSITIONS
BUT ALSO HOW DO WE.
SERIOUSLY SIT DOWN A TRANSITION
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE A LITTLE
MORE CHALLENGE IN GETTING THERE.
MADAM CHAIR MARVIN PINNELL WITH
CAPITA STRATEGIES GROUP HERE
WHAT PRIDE IF I MAY HAVE JUST A
MINUTE TO ANSWER MISTER GREG
JONES SAWYER. I SHE JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION SURPRISED IS THE
NONPROFIT AND WE DO EMPLOY
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WE HAVE
STRONG RELATIONSHIPS WITH. US W.
W. I WOULD WITH OPERATING
ENGINEERS AND WHAT. ANOTHER
UNION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO.
WE HAVE OVER ONE THOUSAND OF OUR
OF OUR WORKERS THAT ARE FAVOR SO
WE WE SUPPORT LABOR I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT AND PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD. AND WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IS WE DO WANT TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE THE WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED I HAD THE WHOLE
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER THE
CONTRACT COULD EXIST BECAUSE OF
THE CURRENT CODE. AYE THERE IS A
CODE IN THE WOOFERS INSTITUTIONS
CHO DEAD AT THE WAS.
THIS IS HOW THE CONTRACT WAS
PROVIDE TAUGHT US IN DON HAS
MORE BACKGROUND INFORMATION AT
WHICH WE MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
SO THERE IS A A. CODE SECTION
THAT ENCOURAGES US NONPROFITS
THAT IMPOSED WITH DISABILITIES
TO DO SOME OF THESE JOBS AND I
ACTUALLY MARTINEZ IS THE IT'S A
GREAT FRIEND AND WOOD WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS AND. I AND WE
THINK THAT THERE IS A WAY TO GET
OUT SOMEWHERE HERE AND. AT THE
END OF THE DAY YOU OUT. A YEAR
FROM NOW WE COULD BE LOOKING
BACK IN I'M IN THAT MIGHT BE
COMING BACK AND SAYING SOME MOST
OF THESE WORKERS ARE OUT OF A
JOB. WHICH MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR FOR EVERYONE IN FOR US
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE.
.
BUDGET
CRAP FINAL IN ODD THAT WE ARE A
NONPROFIT AND AND ALL OF US AND
YOU HAVE FOR PEOPLE OF PRACTICAL
WILLING IF.
SOMEONE'S.
THE DIRECTORS HIS HANDS ARE
TIED.
WELL WE HAVE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WHERE FLOOR OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY PEOPLE LIKE HIM A
LOT FOR THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
AND SO IF IF IT NEEDS SOME
TWEAKING TO MAKE WHAT YOU WANT
TO DO EASIER TO MAKE.
SHE'S DOING EASIER WILL WE
SHOULD CERTAINLY HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TALKS THANK YOU.
DON'T.
THANK YOU.
AND.
THE THING THAT I'M JUST NOT.
HAVE I GOT SOME HAVE TROUBLE
WRAP MY HEAD AROUND IS IT SEEMS
LIKE A ZERO SUM GAME HERE WHEN
IT'S REALLY NOT.
WE HAVE TWO VERY STRONG.
SO PUBLIC POLICIES THAT WE
OPERATE UNDER AND THAT IS TO TRY
TO NOT CONTRACT OUT. AND HAVE A
STRONG CAPABLE WORKFORCE FOR.
DECISIONS ARE ALL THE REASONS
THAT YOU SAID BUT WE ALSO AS A
MATTER OF PUBLIC POLICY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
DISABILITIES HAVE. A ROLE HAVE A
JOB AND HAVE THAT AS WE HEARD
THE PRIDE. THE ABILITY TO.
THE DIGNITY TO WORK AND AND
PROVIDE HOUSE AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
NOT ALL INCOMPATIBLE SO THERE'S.
THERE HAS TO BE AWAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT IF IT'S MONEY HERE
THAT WHICH IS WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS ALL ABOUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
POTENTIALLY PUT ON THE TABLE
BUT.
THERE THERE'S ALSO OF A.
APPEARS TO BE A CLASH OF
POLICIES THAT SHOULD NOT AND DO
NOT ACTUALLY CLASH.
IF WE'RE SMART.
AND IF WE ENSURE THAT WE CAN
HAVE.
THE WORK FORCE THE WAY WE WOULD
LIKE YOU TO LOOK AND THE WORK
FORCE IT INCLUDES ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
CALIFORNIANS WITH WITH
DISABILITY SO. AND I AM HOPING
WE CAN WORK A LITTLE BIT HARDER
POTENTIALLY. PUT MONEY ON THE
TABLE IF WE NEED TO BUT ENSURE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
WORKING WITH AND AND. WE NEED TO
CHANGE POLICIES WHICH I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE NECESSARILY NEED
TO.
TO ACCOMPLISH THIS BUT.
DO WE WE NEED TO KEEP. PEOPLE
EMPLOYED HERE WHO HAVE BEEN
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND ENSURE THAT THAT
HAPPENED SO. FRUSTRATED THAT
THEY SEEM ZERO SUM IT'S NOT AND
WE NEED TO SORT THIS OUT AND WE
GOT A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO DO
THAT SO I I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
WOULD.
I HAVE THEM.
AND AND MAYBE MISTER MARTINEZ
CAN YOU HAVE CAN LET US KNOW.
.
YEAH I AGREE WITH YOU THAT SEEM
TO SAY IF IT'S.
ON THE SURFACE APPEARS TO BE
RELATIVELY SIMPLE BUT I GUESS IT
REALLY IS NOT MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED. THAN WHAT IT
APPEARS TO BE AND I THINK
EVERYONE'S HEART IS IN THE RIGHT
PLACE. I'M NOT SURE HOW WE GET
THERE IN TERMS OF POLICY IN LAWS
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON.
IT WOULD BE GREAT TO HAVE OUR
MEMBERS WHO WERE ON THE DISABLED
COMMUNITY IS A PART OF THE UNION
AND GETTING THE BENEFITS IN THE
RETIREMENT. AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND I I AND. AND I KNOW
HAVING WORKED WITH A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DISABILITIES THEY ARE OF HARD
WORKING VERY DEPENDABLE AND
LOYAL EMPLOYEES. BETTER THAN
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE
DISABILITIES IN TERMS OF THEIR
CARE FOR THEIR JOB IN THE
PRIVATE THEY HAVE BEEN. AND AND
AND REALLY YOU KNOW OF LIKING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING SOME TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT. FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE WHAT IS PASSED.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THE YOU'VE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR THREE YEARS A
TRANSITION IS COMING.
THEY MOVING FROM PRIVATE TO
CIVIL SERVICE I MEAN I GUESS WHO
BEEN SUED OR SOMETHING IS THAT
IT AND WE LOST THE LAWSUIT WE
LOST SOMETHING. AND AS A RESULT
THAT HAS THAT HAS TO THAT'S
MONTHLY IN ME.
RIGHT IN SO THERE'S THERE'S A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT.
FIRST IS YOU KNOW OF LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND HAS BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN
FIGHTING AGAINST THE CONTRACTING
OUT OF STATE WORK FOR MULTIPLE
REASONS ONE.
AS MISTER JONES SAWYER HAD
MENTIONED THE AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER HAD MENTIONED AT
USUALLY A GREAT COST TO THE
TAXPAYER TO CONTRACT THAT OUT SO
WITH TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS AND OUTSOURCE CONTRACTS
THAT THE STATE HAS.
WE DO THE BEST WE CAN WITH OUR
RESOURCES TO CHALLENGE THOSE.
AND VICIOUS HAPPEN TO BE ONE OF
THOSE CONTRACTS THAT WE
CHALLENGED.
WHEN WE DID CHALLENGE THE
CONTRACT THROUGH THE GRIEVANCE
PROCESS THE.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES.
.
REVIEWED IT. REALIZED IT WAS A
VIOLATION OF THAT GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION AND INSTRUCTED THE
DEPARTMENT TO TRANSITION THAT
CONTRACT AND THE CIVIL SERVICE.
.
SO AND IN THE DEPARTMENT PUT
TOGETHER THIS TRANSITION PLAN IF
THIS.
WAS GRIEVED ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
PROCESS. I THINK IT WOULD BE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE TODAY SO
THE TRANSITION PLANT THAT HAS
BEEN INTRODUCED BY THE
DEPARTMENT INCLUDES.
MANY ELEMENTS TO MOVE ALL OF
THE EMPLOYEES FROM THE PRIDE
CONTRACT AND ITS STATE CIVIL
SERVICE. NOW THIS YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS RELEASED A
CIVIL SERVICE IMPROVEMENT
PROPOSAL THAT'S GOING THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS RIGHT NOW. IT
WOULD MAKE IT MUCH EASIER FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO DRAW FROM THOSE
LESS AS THEY IT MENTIONED
THEY'RE BRINGING MORE PEOPLE ON.
.
AND THAT'S CURRENTLY MOVING.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS RIGHT
NOW TICKET HELP FACILITATE.
MORE PEOPLE COMING ON TO THE TO
THE LESS BUT I'DALSO LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THE LEAP PROGRAM.
I KNOW THAT THEIR IT'S NOT
PERFECT. AND THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT. WE CAN DO TO HELP
FACILITATE FOLKS.
IT WITH DISABILITIES TO NOT ONLY
GET THROUGH THE LESS BUT ALSO
TO.
GAIN EMPLOYMENT PEN IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
REALLY TWO.
.
QUALIFICATIONS THAT A PERSON
WITH DISABILITIES ASKED ME ONE
DAY HAVE TO SHOW THAT THEY HAVE
A DISABILITY AND TWO THAT THEY
CAN PERFORM THE FUNCTIONS OF THE
JOB WHICH.
THE FOLKS THAT HAVE DONE THE
PRIDE CONTRACT THE LAST TWO TO
THREE YEARS HAVE SHOWN THAT THEY
BE THAT THEY MEET BOTH OF THOSE.
SO I THINK WITH THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT. TO.
BRINGING MORE FOLKS.
INTO STATE CIVIL SERVICE ACROSS
THE BOARD WE THINK THAT THERE'S
A PATHWAY THAT EXISTS THAT THE
STATE CAN USE TO
SELECT TAPE THAT TRANSFER OVER.
AND.
AS THE DEPARTMENT HAS MENTIONED
THE TRANSITION STILL HAS
ANOTHER.
WHAT IS IT TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS?
TO BE COMPLETED SO IT'S NOT LIKE
ON JULY FIRST.
STEWART I THERE'S A PERIOD OF
TIME WHERE WE CAN WORK ON THIS
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
COMES OVER AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR.
AND IF.
SURE.
EARLY ON WHEN STATE INTO THE
MIKE SO OKAY. SORRY.
EARLY ON WHEN WE WERE ATTEMPTING
TO PUT TOGETHER THE TRANSITION
PLAN IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE DID TRY TO KIND OF BY FOR
KATE THE PROCESS WE WANTED TO
RETAIN PRIDE ON ONE OF THE YARDS
AT THE C. H. CF. AND UTILIZE
THOSE STAFF TO KIND OF
TRANSITION INTO THE CIVIL
SERVICE YOU KNOW BUT POSITIONS
BUT PRIDE SAID IT WASN'T ENOUGH
FOR THEM. TO DO THAT THAT THAT
PIECE OF PUT THAT ONE YARD AND
SO WE DID LOOK IT OPTIONS. THAT
WE THOUGHT WE POTENTIALLY COULD
GET THROUGH THE PROCESS BY
HAVING IT WILL BIFURCATED WITH.
YOU KNOW ACCOMMODATING PRIDE TO
A DEGREE AND THEN CIVIL SERVICE
THE MAJORITY OF THE POSITIONS
THAT WOULD BE THAT'S TRUE BUT.
THEY DID THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
ENGAGE IN IN THAT CONCEPT DE
THEIR.
MA'AM FROM A ADAM JUST TO
COMMENT BACK ON. IT WAS TWENTY
THREE POSITIONS.
THAT THEN WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE A FEEDER POOL TO CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYEES AND.
THE REQUIREMENTS OF HAVING SIX
MONTHS EXPERIENCE
WOULD HAVE MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO BE THE
FEEDER AND. AND.
ACCOMPLISHED A CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATION WITHIN A PARTICULAR
YARD CAN BE SUCCESSFUL.
TWENTY THREE PEOPLE IS PRETTY
SMALL.
IN THAT SIX MONTH WINDOW OF
EXPERIENCE WOULD REALLY REQUIRED
US TO HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY PEOPLE
ON STAFF AT ANY ONETIME TO BE A
FEEDER PULL. SO IT DIDN'T SEEM
THAT THAT WAS GONNA BE EX
EXCESSIVE ALL OPTION FOR EITHER
PARTY THAT WOULD OF CA COMPOSTED
REQUIREMENT.
SO SO THAT WAS WHERE WE COME
INTO THE DISCUSSION.
LOOKING FOR OTHER OPTIONS.
WE WERE ABLE TO FLEX OUR WORK
FORCE IN PROVIDE JOBS.
BECAUSE WE'RE CONTRACTED FOR
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN
POSITIONS.
BUT WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED FORTY
DEPENDING ON WHAT MONTH IT IS IN
OURS WERE HIRING PEOPLE. SO THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO BE FLEXIBLE
PROVIDE PART TIME JOBS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE CAN ONLY
DO FOUR HOURS A DAY OR MAYBE
KILLING DO. YOU KNOW TWENTY
HOURS A WEEK.
WHICH I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED WE ALSO
PROVIDE YOU TRANSPORTATION FOR
EMPLOYEES TO DISABILITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE ANY WAY OF GETTING TO
WORK.
.
I DON'T THINK THOSE COUNSELING
AND JOB COACHING.
.
THE BENEFITS WOULD BE THERE ARE
UNDER THE STATE'S CIVIL SERVICE%
AND THAT WE PROVIDE THAT MAKES
OUR EMPLOYEES SO SUCCESSFUL.
IN A VERY DIFFICULT ENVIRONMENT.
I I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WILL
WORK.
.
KEEPING THE FACILITY IN
COMPLIANCE WHICH IT HASN'T BEEN
WHICH YOU KNOW WENT INTO
RECEIVERSHIP IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
BECAUSE OF ALL THE ISSUES THAT
WERE WITHIN THE FACILITY. TODAY
IT'S IT'S A HUNDRED PERCENT IN
THE PRIVATE AREA THERE ARE NO
DEFICIENCIES.
YOU KNOW AUDITOR DID ANOTHER
REVIEW LAST WEEK WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY ISSUES OUR PAPERWORK OR
COMPLIANCE OR PERFORMANCE. ARE
SECTIONS PAST WEEK PASSED NAY CA
AUDIT OPPOSITE INSPECTOR GENERAL
AUDIT JACO AUDIT AND AUDITOR'S
OFFICE PRODUCTS. AND THAT'S ALL
BECAUSE PRIDES IN THERE NOW
DOING THE WORK SO.
I I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HERE FOR EMPLOYEES WITH
DISABILITIES AND HOPING THAT WE
CAN SAVE THOSE JOBS. NON
PROPOSED DISABILITIES
OKAY.
THERE COMETH THE QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
OKAY OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A.
.
SO THIS IS.
BUT COMPLICATED THE ISSUE AND
WE'VE GOT.
WHERE IT WILL HOLD WE HOLDING
THE ITEM OPEN WE HAVEN'T OUT?
VOTED ON IT AND WE WANT TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN MAKE
THIS WORK. AND THAT'S THE MAIN
GOAL YOU KNOW I KNOW S. YEAH YOU
WANT TO MAKE IT WORK MOST OF US
UP HERE HAVE VOTED AGAINST
OUTSOURCING BECAUSE WE DO
RECOGNIZE. THE VALUE OF BEING A
CIVIL SERVANT AND AND THAT VALUE
IS NOT ONLY FOR. EVERYONE IT'S
ALSO FOR THOSE WHO DISABLED ARAB
TRULY BENEFITS ONE RECEIVES FROM
FROM BEING A PART OF. OF LABOR
ORGANIZATION IN TERMS OF THEIR
LONGEVITY AND RETIREMENT AND
THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO TO
SURVIVE LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE SO
WHAT WE'RE HOLDING THE ITEM OPEN
HOPEFULLY BETWEEN.
NOW AND.
THURSDAY OF WE CAN FIGURE OUT
SOMETHING.
IF NOT IN ACTUAL.
ALLOCATIONS OF SAYS THAT MAYBE
THE LANGUAGE AND INTENT OF WHAT
WE WANT TO ACCOMPLISH WITH THAT
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM ALL OF YOU
IS ALMOST THE SAME THING WE WANT
TO MAKE THIS WORK. AND YOU KNOW
WE BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY IN ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND AND ALL OF US
KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE DISABILITIES TO
GET JOBS.
THEY GET DECENT JOB THAT THEY
CAN UP PARTICIPATED FILL VALUE
AND THAT AND
AND HAVING THOSE HAVE BEEN WORK
FOR THE SYSTEM FOR A COUPLE
YEARS. I KNOW THEY'RE PROBABLY
VERY ATTACHED TO THESE POSITIONS
AND ATTACHED TO THE PEOPLE WHO
IN THE FACILITIES AND ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND SO.
WE WANT TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
IT HAS TO BE SOMETHING THAT
EXISTS IN THE STATE OF. ó THAT.
THAT GIVES US THE ABILITY TO TO
TO SATISFY EVERYONE WE KNOW
WHERE THE TIME CONSTRAINTS AND
AND WE UNDER LAWSUIT SO WE HAVE
TO COMPLY. WITH THAT AND MAKE
THAT TRANSITION BUT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW A IN ADDITION TO
THE RULES THAT WE HAVE TO LIVE
BY. THEIR ALSO INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE. WORKING AND AND AND AND
WANT TO BE A PART OF IT SO HANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT ARE HOPEFULLY WE
WILL BE ABLE TO REACH OUT. TO
YOU REACH OUT TO OUR STAFF THE
NEXT DAY OR SO SO WE CAN TRY TO.
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THIS WORKS AND AND WE KNOW
THE TRANSITION IS SUPPOSED TO
TAKE PLACE OVER HOW LONG IT'S
GONNA TAKE TO DO THE TRANSITION
CITY YEAR. IT'S ABOUT TEN MONTHS
TEN MONTHS SO IT'LL BE HAPPENING
THIS YEAR YEAH AND SO.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO AT LEAST ACCOMMODATE MOST
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WORKING. WITH THEIR WHO KNOW THE
JOB YOU KNOW AND BECAUSE WHEN I
HAVE TO OUR FOLKS ANYWAY AND
ALSO HOPEFULLY. THAT'S A PART OF
THE PROCESS IS NOT LIKE WHICH
PLACE ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE
ANOTHER GROUP OF PEOPLE. YOU
KNOW THE OF THOSE JOBS AT THE
AND THIS THAT AND. TWO HUNDRED
SOME PEOPLE WHO WOULD THAT WOULD
REPLACE IT OTHER THAN OF THOSE
THAT ARE AT THE POSITION SO WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT SOME
WAY TO MAKE IT WORK.
SO THAT THOSE CAN CONTINUE. I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR COMING THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
I THINK THAT THAT BRINGS US TO
THE CONCLUSION TODAY.
LISTA WE HAVE MISTER LACKEY HAS
BEEN VOTING TO DO YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M SORRY THIS BILL LACKEY WANTS
TO MAKE A MOTION.
OKAY YOU THROUGH THIS SEVENTIES
IT.
SO I'M GOING TO CALL THANK GOD
BECAUSE I WAS LIKE I USUALLY DO
THAT TODAY NO. COMES RIGHT OKAY.
BETH RIGHT MISSED LEG WOULDN'T
MOVE IF I KNOW BUT IF I WAS KIND
OF CONCERN IS WHAT IT SOUNDED
LIKE IT'S GONNA GO BACK OVER
THOSE ITEMS THAT YOU WOULD NOT
HEAR FOR. BEGINNING FIFTY ONE
YES BEGINNING WITH A FIFTY ONE.
ITEM FIFTY ONE.
SEE WITH TELL YOU WHAT THE VOTE
WAS FIFTY.
CORD.
FIFTY ONE WAS FOUR ZERO OKAY.
.
ITEM FIFTY ONE MISTER LACKEY.
OKAY. THAT MAKES IT FIVE ZERO
ITEM FIFTY TWO.
I'VE.
IT'S I THAT MAKES FIVE ZERO ITEM
FIFTY TWO.
MISTER LACKEY WE DID.
.
FIFTY THREE THROUGH FIFTY SEVEN.
AND THE VOTERS WHO FOUR ZERO SO
MISTER LACKEY FIVE. FIVE ZERO ON
ITEM FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY SEVEN.
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT A CONSOLIDATION
OF VICTIM PROGRAMS. I THAT MAKES
A FIVE ZERO.
I DON'T FIFTY NINE THROUGH SIXTY
THAT'S FOUR ZERO RIGHT NOW.
WISEMAN SELECTABLE I'VE TO BOTH
OF THOSE SO THAT MAKES IT FIVE
ZERO. ITEM SIXTY ONE THE
HOMELESS YOUTH AND EXPLOITATION
PROGRAM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTERS AND SERVICES THAT VOTES
KILEY FOUR ZERO.
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO MISTER THAT
IS HIGH FOR ITEM SIXTY ONE. ITEM
SIXTY TWO THROUGH SIXTY FOUR
APPROVAL OF VARIOUS BRING
LETTERS THAT'S A FOUR ZERO VOTE
RIGHT NOW MISTER LACKEY.
IT'S A FIVE ZERO VOTE OKAY THIS
CLOSED OUT ITEM SIXTY FIVE TO
SIXTY SIX THAT'S CURRENTLY A
FOUR ZERO VOTE.
THAT'S.
THAT MAKES IT FIVE ZERO MISTER
LACKEY ITEM SIXTY SEVEN OH PILOT
PROJECT OF ONLINE ADJUDICATION
OF TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS THAT
CURRENTLY IS A FOUR ZERO VOTE.
MISTER LACKEY FIVE THAT'S FIVE
ZERO ITEM SIXTY SEVEN OF SIXTY
EIGHT THE SELF HELP US CENTER.
THAT ITEM RIGHT NOW AS I IS
FOUR ZERO MISTER LACKEY.
IT'S FIVE ZERO ITEM SIXTY NINE
THE COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE IN REDUCTION OF LOVE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE BUDGET IS CURRENTLY A
THREE WITH NO VOTING.
THAT MISTER LIND IS.
YOUR VOTE MISTER LACKEY NO VOTE
OKAY SO THAT'S THREE IT'S OUT ON
THREE WOULD TO NOT VOTING.
OKAY.
THAT BEING SAID I THINK WE'VE
COVERED ALL THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH IN
THE MEETING IS ADJOURNED